WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO THE
CURVE IT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCE SEES A FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDINGOUR COMMITTEE
HEARING HERE IN THE CAPITAL TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN TWO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT. RIGHT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. ONCE AGAIN.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN THREE SIX.
TWO EIGHT THREE ONE. ONCE AGAIN
SEVEN THREE SIX. TWO EIGHT
THREE ONE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE SEE THE SENATE OR OR
WEBSITE. AT OF INSURANCE
COMMITTEE. WHAT WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE IN ZERO FOUR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. PLEASE PRESS IS
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LIGHT
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL
BE ON MUTE IT AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. PLEASE NOTE
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY.
ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DISRUPTED MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN ASK
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IT
IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING TO A NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL. INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. TODAY WE
HAVE THREE BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. FIRST WE WILL ESTABLISH
A QUORUM CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE INITIAL
CONSISTENT RUBIO. YEAH RUBIO
HERE JOHN. JOHN JONES HERE
JONES HERE PARTULA HERE
ARCHULETA HERE BAIT HERE. IT'S
HERE BORDERS PRESENT. BORDERS
HERE DOT HERE START HERE GLAZER.
GLAZER HERE HUESO OKAY HUESO
HERE GLAZER NOT PRESENT.
HURTADO MELENDEZ. PORTANTINO
HERE PORTANTINO HERE ROB HERE
BROUGHT HERE. WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM WE WILL
NOW WELCOME OUR FIRST AUTHOR
WELCOME SENATOR GONZALEZ YOU
MAY NOT PRESENT SB TWO EIGHTY
THREE WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR GOOD MORNING-
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND-
INSURANCE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT
I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB TWO
EIGHTY THREE WHICH STRENGTHENS
THE EQUAL INSURANCE BY CHEVY
ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY. ALASTOR
THIS COMMITTEE PASSED THE EQUAL
INSURANCE HIV ACT WHICH
PROHIBITS INSURERS FROM
DECLINING INSURANCE APPLICATION
OR ENROLLMENT SOLELY BASED ON
POSITIVE HIV TESTS. SB TWO
EIGHTY THREE JUST MAKES
CLARIFYING AND UPDATING
TECHNICAL CHECK CHANGES TO THE
PROVISIONS THAT WE ARE SET
FORTH BY THE EQUAL INSURANCE
HIV ACT SPECIFICALLY THE BILL
WOULD PROHIBIT INSURERS FROM
CONSIDERING APPLICATIONS ARE AN
APPLICANT'S OCCUPATION WHICH
WAS OMITTED FROM THE ACT LAST
YEAR IN DETERMINING WHETHER TO
REQUIRE AN HIV TEST. MORE OVER
IT CLARIFIES EXISTING LAW WHICH
ALLOWS INSURERS TO LIMIT
BENEFITS PAYABLE FOR A LOST
CAUSE FOR CONTRIBUTED BY HIV IF
THEY COULD HAVE DECLINED AN
APPLICANT DURING THE INITIAL
MEDICAL UNDERWRITING PROCESS
BUT THEY CHOSE TO ISSUE
COVERAGE INSTEAD. OF CONTINUE
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO CLARIFY THAT
FRAUD AND MISREPRESENTATION ARE
STILL VALID REASONS TO LIMIT
BENEFITS AND WILL WORK TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE BEFORE THE
ACT GOES INTO EFFECT ON JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE
FINALLY THIS BILL WILL CONFORM
THE PENALTY OF IMPRISONMENT
UNDER THE EQUAL INSURANCE HIV
ACT TO NOT EXCEED THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FOUR CALENDAR DAYS AS
ESTABLISHED UNDER CURRENTLY
UNDER EXISTING LAW. IT IS ALSO
CRITICAL IN STRENGTHENING
PROTECTIONS AND ENSURING THAT
THE EQUAL INSURANCE HIV ACT IS
IMPLEMENTED AS IT WAS INTENDED
TO TODAY TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
I HAVE KOENDERS ALERT DEPUTY
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE AND
TAMMY MARTIN LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA AND ON STAND BY WE
ALSO HAVE NANCY HOME AND WINDY
HILL TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE WHEN
APPROPRIATE FOR S. B. TWO
EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU SENATOR WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TWENTY ONE WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. BUT
BEFORE WE DO PLEASE NOTE THE
EACH SIDE WILL BE PERMITTED TO
COLUMN OF TIME NOT TO EXCEED
MINUTES. ALL OTHER WORDS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION. AND POSITION ON
THE MEASURE. WE WILL START WITH
KENDRA SOLAR FROM. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. HUNDRED DOLLAR ON
BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. WE
ARE THE PROUD SPONSORS OF SB
THREE AND WOULD LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR CONSOLIDATES FOR
OFFERING THAT MEASURE AND HER
TEACHING YOU'D COMMITMENT TO
HEALTH EQUITY FOR ALL.I WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN BY SAYING THAT
THE DEPARTMENT IS COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING FASHIONING AND
WORKING WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS-
AND OUTSTANDING EIGHT YEARS.
NEED BE RESOLVED AS- MUCH
FASTER. LAST YEAR AGO NEEDS TO
SIGN THE EAGLE INSURANCE ACT HI
AND SALAS BUT YOU KNOW WHAT IT
OUT BOB. IN THE NATION
ADVENTURE AB BASED ON ON THE-
THAT. WHEN HIV UNDER RIGHT ON
THE STREET AND- FOR SUMMER WHO
HAD EIGHT POSITIVE GROWTH EARLY
PLANNING IN WHAT IT DOES
REDUCED THE LIFE SIX. TODAY ACT
TO QUALITY HEALTHCARE AT AT IN
EACH TESTING AND- EFFORT NO
LEARN THEIR I THINK ARE. LITTLE
LONGER HEALTHIER LIFE NEVER BE-
NEED FOR LIFE. SHARON IT'S
IMPERATIVE IN ORDER TO PROTECT
AND THEIR- SB TWO EIGHT THREE
THANK NUMBER. THERE FOR IT IS
THANK AND PROTECTION STARTED
THAT THE PEOPLE IN ERRAND EIGHT
I FEEDBACK IT IMPLEMENTED AS IT
WERE TANK. ON BEHALF OF ENSURE
COMMISSIONER LARA I ASKED.
THANK YOU. CAN WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO TIME MARTIN. THE CALLER
CAL. THANK GOOD MORNING TO
COMMITTEE. I'LL BE BRIEF
MESSAGE CAN BE MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA. PROUD CO SPONSOR
OF A TWO EIGHTY THREE ALONG
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA. LIKE ITS PREDECESSOR THE
ENSURING H. I. ACT OF TWENTY
TWO. SB TWO EIGHTY THREE AND
THE BILL THAT AT ITS CORE IS
ABOUT NOT DISCRIMINATING
AGAINST SOMEONE BECAUSE OF
THEIR HIV STATUS AND
MODERNIZING CALIFORNIA'S
OUTDATED LAWS RELATING TO HIV.
REALLY THANK SENATOR GONZALEZ
AND THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
FOR CONTINUING TO CHAMPION THE
EFFORT WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT TODAY TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S LAWS
LIKE SCIENCE NOT STIGMA THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AS MARTIN WE
WILL MOVE ON TO WITNESSES HERE
IN THE GALLERY. SEEING NONE WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. C. NINE. FINALLY WE
WILL MOVE ON TO SUPPORT
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
THE OTHER TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR PLEASE POP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO EIGHTY
THREE AND PLEASE OPEN THE LINE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
A TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF BILL
S. B. TWO EIGHT ZERO PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY THE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AT EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOU YOUR
LINE NUMBER OFFLINE. AT ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. AGAIN FOR
EVERYBODY IF YOU'D LIKE TO TEST
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL SB TWO
EIGHT ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. MODERATOR CAN YOU LET ME
KNOW HOW MANY COLORS WE HAVE
WAITING. WE JUST HAVE ONE WITH
AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT. ALL.
YEAH. ONE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- THIS IS MATT
POWERS OF THE POSITION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES WELL WE
ARTIFICIALLY SUPORT WE ARE
WORKING TO GET THERE AND I DO
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
STAFF AND SPONSORS FOR THE WORK
IN THE PAST TWO YEARS. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S-
COMMENTS REGARDING SECTION
THREE SEVEN NINE NINE POINT
ZERO EIGHT. HI WE HAVE EVERY
CONFIDENCE IT WILL LAND IN A
GOOD PLACE. SO WE ABSOLUTELY
DISTORTION CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
ANYONE ELSE WAITING TO SPEAK
BETTER. NO MADAM CHAIR THERE'S
NO BETTER PARTISAN WITHOUT.
THANK YOU NOW WE WILL MOVE OVER
TWENTY WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
TWO EIGHTY THREE HERE IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NONE WERE NOW
MOVING ON TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. C. NINE THAT THANK
YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OUR
WITNESSES WISHING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES.
THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION S. B. TWO
EIGHTY THANK YOU PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND AS A REMINDER TO TESTIFYING
IN OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT ZERO.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND I
APOLOGIZE IT IS THE BILL NUMBER
IS. TWO EIGHTY THREE. IS THERE
ANYONE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION MODERATOR PLEASE
GIVE ME THE NUMBER NOBODY IS.
GOING THANK YOU WE WILL NOW
MOVE OVER TO MEMBER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. C. NINE- I JUST
WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR FROM
LONG BEACH FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FORWARD I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING WITH YOU
ON THIS LAST YEAR. AND THIS IS
A CRITICAL STEP TOWARDS TAPPING
THE UNFAIR DISCRIMINATION OF
INDIVIDUAL SELF THANK YOU AND
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
YOUR WORK AS WELL AND I JUST
WANT TO THANK OUR- CO SPONSORS
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA AND THE INSURANCE
DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS A QUALITY
CALIFORNIA FOR THEIR WORK WITH.
WITH- WITH ME AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU THANK IS THERE MOTION.
MOVED BY SENATOR ROTH.
CONSULTANCIES TO ROLL CALL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS RUBIO HI
RUBIO I JONES HI JONES HI
ARCHULETA HI. ARCHULETA HI
BATES HI BATES HI FORTUS FIVE
BORDERS I DON. HI DODD I GLAZER.
HUESO HI HUESOON HER TADO.
MELENDEZ PORTANTINO HI UNTIL HI
RALPH HI. ROTH I. THE BILL HAS
NINE VOTES. FOR HOME. NINE YES
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THIS BILL
IS OUT WITH NINE I KNOW KNOWS.
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO CONSENT
CALENDAR THERE ARE TWO BILLS
AND CONVEYING CALENDAR SB
ELEVEN AND SB SEVENTY TWO. DO I
HAVE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MOVED BY SENATOR
WITHOUT CONSULTING PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE SECOND CYCLE
UNDER RUBIO YEAH I RELY JONES I
DON'T HI ARE TOO HI VIRTUAL
ONLINE BATES HI. HI BORDERS HI
FOUR HI DON HI DODD OUR PLEASE.
HUESO HI HUESO ONLINE FOR TWO.
MELENDEZ PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO
I ROTH AYE ROTH HI. THE BILL
HAS NINE VOTES FOR. CONSENT
CALENDAR HAS NINE VOTES THEY
CAN THANK CALA HAS NINE I WOULD
CHOOSE HOLD THE PIN FOR A FEW.
PERHAPS MEMBERS.
I WILL NOW
OPEN THE ROLE. FOR SB TWO
EIGHTY THREE FOR THOSE ABSENT
MEMBERS. CONSULTANT. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. SB. TWO EIGHTY THREE.
THIRTY TWO EIGHTY THREE.
CURRENT VOTERS IN NINE TWO ZERO
GLAZER. HER TADO HER TITLE I
MELENDEZ. BELINDA'S HI. NERO IS.
ELEVEN ZERO. SEVEN MOTION IS TO
PASS. FOR TWO EIGHTY THREE
ELEVEN I KNOW ZEROS WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS WE WILL NOW
MOVE OVER TO CONSENT CALENDAR I
CONSULTANCIES CALL THE ROLL.
CONSENT CALENDAR CURRENT VOTERS
NINETY ZERO. GLAZER HURTADO HER
TÁI MELENDEZ. BLENDERS ARE
WHAT IS ELEVEN DESERVE CONSENT
CALENDAR HAS ELEVEN TWO ZERO WE
WILL CONTINUE TO HOLD THIS OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU.
WE WILL NOW OPEN THE ROLE FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS WE WILL GO TO SB
TWO EIGHTY THREE CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB TWO
EIGHTY THREE THE PAST CURRENT
VOTERS ELEVEN ZERO GLAZER.
LATER I VOTE IS TWELVE ZERO.
BILL SB TWO EIGHTY THREE IS OUT
TWELVE FIVE AND NO ZEROS WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO CONSENT
CALENDAR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CURBELO CONSENT CALENDARS
ELEVEN TWO ZERO GLAZER. PLEASE-
I. LOTUS TWELVE TO ZERO THAT
CAN SOUND A CONTENT CALENDAR IS
OUT TWELVE I NO NO THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE NOW
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA THE
COMMITTEE ON INSURANCE IS NOW
ADJOURNED. HAVE A GOOD DAY.